claudia schiffer bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est pas un petit peu déçu d'être
au festival de cannes pour l'oréal et
pas pour un pas pour un film non c'est
avec un plaisir que je suis là j'étais
et c'est avec black ainsi à 4 ans et la
gelée avec l'oréal et c'est si bien et
malheureusement et pleut donc ça c'est
pas trop génial alors vous avez une
enfance très heureuse dans une famille
harmonieuse affectueuse vous avez été
élevé à la campagne d'été bonne élève
vous appreniez le piano est très fier
très sage vos parents étaient vos idoles
vouliez travaux 4 comme votre père vous
n'êtes pas eu de crise d'adolescence
et puis un jour dans une boîte de nuit
un
jour un jour dans une boîte de nuit à
düsseldorf vous aviez 17 ans vous étiez
vous étiez jamais et vous étiez jamais
venu dans cette boîte de nuit et vous
avez été découverte par le patron d'une
agence de mannequins ça s'est passé
comment claudia
jeu j'y croyais pas je pensais qu'il
sentait en train de sarah en fait d'un
faute je me suis dit vin les français en
plus alors 4 à 6 ans ils sont en train
de me draguer uniquement et mon père est
avocat et ils ont parlé avec un parent
lendemain et oui c'était plus simple de
discuter directement avec le beau père
qui est avocat moi je me suis dit vaut
mieux qu'ils parlent avec eux et et j'ai
commencé à signer un contrat et je suis
venu après après l'école je suis
carrément
elle est à paris pour commencer mais
alors est-ce que cette cette enfance
très très sage finalement cette nature
très studieuse vous fumez pas vous buvez
pas vous droguez pas est ce que
finalement
ça n'a pas pour conséquence que vous
manquez un petit peu de deux cicatrices
intérieur pour faire du cinéma est ce
que vous croyez pas que c'est un
handicap pour faire du cinéma d'avoir
une vie aussi aussi lisse avant vous
fais partie des gens qui pensent qu'il
faut prendre un drop pour être bien non
rien d'acteurs qui pense
je veux dire c'est quand on a eu est ce
que finalement quand on a quand on a
vécu que des choses bien les choses
gaies que des choses heureuses est ce
qu'on est capable cinéma d'exprimer des
sentiments négatifs et des situations un
peu douteuse un peu glauque un peu
triste oui c'est vrai que dans
l'enseignement et moins tu entends
d'entrée je travaille beaucoup avec mes
émotions c'est vrai que c'est important
d'avoir des souvenirs dans la vie
positifs et négatifs et ben c'est vrai
ma vie normale comme tout le monde j'ai
des abcès n'daw comme tout le monde et
le fait que je ne prends pas la drogue
ou que je me suis pas alcoolique ça
change rien j'ai quand même mes émotions
qui font un peu en haut et en bas et
voilà et j'aime beaucoup rigolé donc
voilà on pouvait faire des films
comiques au moins
est ce que c'est pour ça est ce que
c'est pour casser un petit peu cette
image un peu un peu lisse que vous avez
accepté le film black out réalisé par
abel ferrara qui avait fait quand même
bagdad nantes avec harvey castle est ce
que c'est parce que c'était un allumé
ferrara qu'ils avaient accepté slint non
parce que vous savez je ne fais pas un
film en disant ah ben je vais faire ce
film pour casser mon image j'ai fait ce
film parce que j'adore le réalisateur et
j'aimais beaucoup le scénario et en plus
j'avais jamais fait un film donc six
points c'est aix et même en acceptant de
trouver finalement quelque chose que
j'aimais tellement donc je n'ai jamais
misé l'univers de ferrara est quand même
très très loin de votre univers avoue
non traite différents en plus pour mon
caractère dans ce film par exemple il
fallait pas de maquillage et de coiffure
c'était génial je suis arrivé sur le cnt
avait rien à faire et et comme c'était
mon premier film je ne savais pas c'est
le réalisateur maintenant était normale
entre guillemets ou si tout le monde
était comme ça ou c'est et excentrique
ferment donc il y avait martine au dîner
donné sympa qui n'arrêtait pas de me
dire tu sais c'est pas normal il est pas
normal vous avez dit inutile de
m'envoyer des scénarios à la pretty
woman parce que pour moi ce serait
suicidaire de faire un film comme ça
voyez deux chaussures cherche en fait
les rôles qui sont très différents de
moi comme par exemple dans le film black
heart ou dans le fait mieux exemple
black and white parce que je joue
quelqu'un qui est pas très gentil du
tout où j'ai par exemple j'ai fait un
autre fait mon agrès coup je fais une
âme je suis une chanteuse avait m donc
j'adore ça c'est très très différents et
en plus ce sens je pense que pour moi en
tant que débutante j'ai tellement de
choses encore à apprendre il vaut mieux
commencer avec les expériences dans les
petits films avec les réalisateurs qui
sont très ouverts à travailler avec les
débutantes alors je disais que la dia en
commençant cette interview je disais que
vous avez une vie très très heureuse et
tout de suite beaucoup de succès tout de
suite gagné beaucoup d'argent fait
beaucoup de couvertures de magazines
pourtant vous avez une expérience assez
négative ces quelques années avant de
faire le film citroën où il y avait le
crash test vous avez failli vous crachez
en avion en 96 aux antilles il ya la
porte vous étiez dans un petit avion il
ya la porte arrière qui s'est ouvert ce
oui je vais faire un voyage en fait à
belize et c'était un tout petit avion en
fait à peu près pour 4 personnes et
six mois dans la viande derrière il y
avait le pilote devant un seul pilote
est en fête heureusement c'était
seulement un petit voyage de huit
minutes mais quand on est content a
commencé à monter la porte de mon côté
c'est ouvert et je vais une ceinture
donc je mets la ceinture autour de la
poignée de la porte j'étais là comme ça
entre un espoir et j'espère que la poste
a pas offert parce que si elle s'ouvre
c'est fini parce que je m'en vais avec
et tu gardé la porte comme ça j'ai
essayé de parler avec le pilote a qui
étaient là mais tu sais que vous savez
portent les grands choses là sous les
oreilles donc c'est beaucoup si maman
télé m'a pas entendu et finalement après
huit minutes on est descendu et il n'y a
pas de problème est-ce que c'était le
plus mauvais moment de votre vie non et
bien d'autres enfin incident dans un
avion il y avait un
oiseau qui est allé dans un soutien
l'avion privé à un oiseau est allé dans
un mentor le moteur a commencé à
exploser à prendre du feu et il y avait
plein de mentir brouillard smoke smoke
qui est venu rentrer dans l'avion il y
en a fait un crash lundi ohlala
heureusement il n'y avait rien du tout
c'est une spécialiste des crash
finalement c'est oui j'ai beaucoup de
chance alors vous êtes une fille une
fille sage quand même mais vous avez
quand même des rapports avec les avec
les garçons qui sont pas toujours très
clair quand vous avez quand on vous a vu
quelquefois avec le prince albert vous
avez dit ce n'est qu'un ami et l'été
dernier quand on a commencé à vous voir
avec le playboy londonien team jeffries
on vous a demandé pourquoi vous étiez
avec lui vous aviez vous avez dit ce
n'est qu'un vieil ami alors pourquoi à
chaque fois que l'on vous voit avec un
garçon vous êtes obligé de dire c'est un
ami ou c'est un vieil ami et menacé de
tribunaux les gens qui écrirait autre
chose est-ce que vous avez un problème
avec les relations avec les hommes avec
les garçons
bon d'abord je dois dire que
si je dis que c'est un ami c'est un ami
c'est jeudi c'est mon amant c'est mon
amant we meet in g freeze enfin le
prince albert je suis sûr que c'était
pas votre amant mais tim jeffries c'est
devenu quand même un ami très très très
très proche par la suite quand même non
c'est la france qui a des sas et enfin
moi il faut pas te croire vous savez non
non moi quand je dis que c'est c1
amoureux ou c'est mon petit copain c'est
la vérité si je lis est mon ami la
vérité je ne mens pas mais si la presse
marc une chose pareille vous savez le
plus connaît le plus connu connaît rien
à faire les gens maréchaussée à 20 des
choses disait chose même entre
guillemets que je n'ai jamais dis donc
rien à faire
bon pourquoi je dirais que c'était pas
vrai si c'était vrai alors puisque dit
toujours la vérité est ce que c'est vrai
que vous allez vous marier avec tim
jeffries d'approbation fiancée et a pas
encore une table bien vous avez vous
avez changé d'avis un petit peu sur le
mariage parce que en 1998 où didier le
mariage c'est pas très important
ni même nécessaire dont vous avez un
petit peu changé d'avis sur le mariage
non en fait c'est ce que j'avais dit
c'est que à ce moment là le mariage
n'était pas important encore parce que
je pense que si on veut se marrer et à
voir les enfants il faut être frontière
quand il veut avoir une date certain
moment il faut être prête à voyager
moins on peut pas tout faire parce que
c'est important je pense que pour les
enfants commencent à la maison et
à cette époque là est d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas encore prête
pour les enfants parce que tellement de
choses que je faire encore c'est encore
trop tôt vous n'allez pas vous marier
tout de suite a tout de suite
et alors avec david copperfield comment
ça s'est terminé parce qu'un journal
allemand qui s'appelle bounty qui avait
publié un contrat entre david
copperfield et vous vous les avez
attaqué au tribunal et vous avez gagné
donc c'était le journal boon qui avait
publié des faux documents bah oui c'est
j'ai gagné ça veut dire ça ouais ça veut
dire donc il ya jamais eu de contrat
d'affaires entre david copperfield et
vous et si je gagnais oui ça n'existait
pas non d'accord si je gagne un procès
ça veut dire ça non oui oui
oui non ça trouve encore enfant il faut
pas tout croire même si un papier même
si à tout un coin signature il faut pas
te croire d'accord
la merci beaucoup merci claudio de nous
avoir accordé cette interview exclusive
et bon séjour à cannes
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus